محملة بالخبز والإمدادات الأخرى
، هي وأصدقاؤها جزء من
جهد تطوعي هائل
يملأ الفراغ الذي تركته الحكومة
والنخبة السياسية
التي يبدو أنها لم
تفعل شيئًا يذكر على الأرض
لأنها لا تفعل شيئًا لأنها
تجلس في منازلها  إنفاق أموالنا
، من السخف أن الدولة في شكل
الدرك موجودة في شوارع
حي جبل محايل المتضرر بشدة
جالسًا ومشاهدة مالك المتجر إيلي اللطوف
لم يستبعد المساعدة الحكومية في
النهاية.
ومع ذلك ، لا يزال الوقت
مبكرًا ، سيستغرق الأمر سبع أو ثماني سنوات
، ويقول إنه
لم يأت أحد من الدولة للاطمئنان
علينا ، ولا أحد
يقول إن زوجته ليلى أبدًا نشكر
الأشخاص الذين
ساعدونا صاحب المتجر ، صلاح كاموا ، الذي يتطلع
إلى ما وراء حدود لبنان للحصول على المساعدة
لا لا لا إذا لم يكن لدينا دعم من
خارج لبنان
فلن يستطيعوا فعل أي شيء
يقول محافظ بيروت إن تكلفة الضرر ستصل
إلى
خمسة مليارات دولار على الأقل.  لقد خصصت الحكومة
66 مليون دولار للإغاثة من الكوارث
ولإعادة الإعمار
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، ووافقت الدول المانحة على
تزويد لبنان بما يقرب من 300 مليون
دولار كمساعدات طارئة ، لكن هذه المساعدة
تأتي بشرط محدد للغاية
يجب ألا يتم تمريرها من خلال
الحكومة اللبنانية على
الأرجح إلى  تأكد من عدم وقوعها
في جيوب المسؤولين الفاسدين ، حتى أن
مجموعة من سكان كوريا الجنوبية
أقامت خيمة
حيث يقدمون وجبات خفيفة المرطبات
وأقنعة للوجه
في الشوارع هنا مع متطوعين
يساعدون ولكنهم يستطيعون
من بينهم nadine
الجميع يهتم ببعضه البعض  لكن
لدينا حكومة لا تهتم
لأمرنا ، فالعديد من أوجه القصور في
الدولة اللبنانية معروفة للناس هنا
وأن الألفة لم تولد
سوى الازدراء.